rest in peace to tyrone woodley is all i
gotta say
rest in peace to tyler with me because i
will never ever ever watch you fight
ever again you broke my heart into a
million [ __ ] pieces and here's the
thing it didn't have to happen that way
it didn't didn't have to happen that way
do you really think he's going to fight
ever again well he made like four
million that's not a look let me tell
you haley four million like four million
he didn't he didn't make like a
gajillion yeah made like four mill he
probably made more on the side too but
in five four three two one hello
everybody welcome to another
mother
episode of the genius brain podcast you
stupid sons of
you don't cuss on here no more oh i
stopped cursing why because i'm trying
to monetize i'm trying to pay bills you
stupid bags so that really does mess
with the monetization just only in the
first like 10 minutes or so once the 10
minutes pass your boy cursing up a
[ __ ] star
i'm gonna look at the time stamp and
then we're gonna look back and it's like
yeah dude [ __ ] youtube
i lost it
the lights are turning off right now
he's like in five four it restarts yeah
that would be a tough challenge to not
be able to cuss i don't think i can
because i think we curse too much we
can't do it it's not possible for pieces
of trash i've been oh
i cut too much yeah it's just i don't
know though because i work retail and
you can't cuss
you know what i'm saying actually i
think i could probably do it if i know
that if you tell me hey you can't cuss
for 10 minutes i will be good but it's
in the comfort of friendships and it's
too hard not to curse that's true i cuss
in front of my clients all the time yeah
that's because you're a piece of [ __ ]
science is different though that's
that's true that's right yeah and
no one like really cares
no one's ever gotten mad at me forever
gary vee dude you're even dressed like
garyvee today i know looking at you
are [ __ ] telling me to wake up and
start doing more work and [ __ ]
do more work you need to be posting
every single day give us your three tips
for success right now garyvee all right
uh post every single day if you're not
talking to anybody about your business
you're failing that's that's that's not
right you would be post every [ __ ]
day if you're not [ __ ] posting you're
[ __ ] failing yeah that's more like
don't even ask me for advice if you're
not posting every single [ __ ] day
that's what that's something he was
saying
don't be a [ __ ] bag that's like davis oh
garyvee style you know what i mean
perfect easy number three you should be
posting more every single day that's
exactly all he talks about how can i
talk like garyvee but i'm poor tell me
why
i don't know because you [ __ ] post
yeah
that's how he sounds he has that voice
you know [ __ ] post i [ __ ] cuss
because i [ __ ] want you i was
watching uh i just started i just
started following uh garyvee and i've
been binge watching his stuff like you
know his stuff is just pretty much just
common sense stuff yeah what a lot of
people just have inhibitions so they
don't do what they're supposed to do but
half his post is him just saying that
you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
that you're a lazy you're a lazy he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] i think people are grown up
with like abuse from parenting so they
need that from like a business guy just
to tell them like hey you need to do
this [ __ ] too you piece of trash it's
like the coach like a coach on a sports
team yeah it's like you that hard one
right that's cussing it's like pushing
you bro that's why those guys are like
this is you don't want the coaches like
that's why none of nick's fighters ever
win dude yeah it's too nice i'm too nice
i'm like and then the moment i'm not
there heinrich smashes everybody you
know yeah that's what happened number
one number one brother you don't protect
anybody brother yeah that's true huh
what happened
[Music]
oh yeah see this is what we got to talk
about man so
we we haven't talked you know what
rest in peace to town woodley is all i'm
going to say
rest in peace to tyler because i will
never ever ever watch you fight ever
again you broke my heart into a million
[ __ ] pieces and here's the thing it
didn't have to happen that way it didn't
didn't have to happen that way do you
really think he's gonna fight ever again
well he made like four million that's
not a look let me tell you haley four
million like four million he didn't make
like a gajillion yeah made like four mil
he probably made more on the side too
but you know rappers be using money dude
he's a rapper now you see his music
video he has a new one out he didn't see
the one with him
yeah he released it right before
the jake paul fight
and it had one of those like old school
like it was very like very 2000s bro
like they had a little skit right before
and that was way too long it was way too
long and the skit had the name of the
song is what go big go big go big and
then the hook is like let's go big or
whatever i don't know but then the whole
time he's sitting with this guy ot
genesis who's another rapper who i don't
really like personally yeah he was like
i'm in love with the coco yeah i don't
like that song like that song is not
catchy to me i don't [ __ ] with it but
he's sitting next to tom really at a
party in a nice ass house of course and
he's nice-sized [ __ ] hey yo we need
to go big dog we need to go big and he's
like oh my god let's go big and he's
like let's go big and i keep going back
and forth and then they get into the
song but that lasted way too long and i
think that's the reason why he lost a
jake paul fight
it's like he should have learned because
he released that capital t
because he released i forgot which i
think it was right before the kamaru's
been fighting wow yeah he released that
song the day before and then got his ass
beat you know what's funny there was a
there's a really funny meme on reddit on
like the ufc page and we're saying since
tyrone woodley dropped that song he has
not beat anyone's ass no
100
you know what the thing is is like the
lead up to the fight was so good because
tyrone woodley was roasting the [ __ ] out
of jake paul he was amazing and the face
to face i was like this is i wish we saw
this town would be more in the ufc
because he was hilarious he was killing
him like verbally
and like super calm like jake paul had
some good little jabs in there like
talking some [ __ ] and tyler really
handled it very well and threw right
back at him and i was like wow that was
very good was it dr pedro diaz yeah yeah
all your fighters are kind of sucking
right now huh what's going on
paige van zandt we'll talk about it
later on this podcast too they just he
just needs more time with them honestly
but here's the thing
so i'll put this on twitter i was so
[ __ ] mad and people were like how
dare you talk to a former ufc champ i
was like dude he's one of my favorite
welterweights in the history of the ufc
yeah all his fights were [ __ ] bangers
just knocking people out so you don't
say [ __ ] to me about tyron woodley i was
yeah i was disappointed right because
when you looked at this fight right and
here's the problem too
he put it out there he's the one that
said i have never been able to let my
hands go that's why you guys haven't
seen what i can do as a boxer right i'm
gonna start using my jab more i have
these combos you guys haven't seen
nothing yet yeah this is the full
through like six jabs throughout the
whole fight and by the way when he did
throw his jab he connected yeah and he
chose not to do it he is so worried
about about getting knocked out he's
he's mentally [ __ ] he's like too
worried about looking cool now yeah he's
like i can't get touched by this and
that's that's the part of the trap right
when you fight a guy like jake paul it's
not really about the fight anymore
because obviously on paper town really
knows he could smash his fool if you
wanted to or whatever the kid right
you're like a normal fight yeah yes but
if you're scrapping with somebody that's
just boxing
i think it's kind of similar to the
logan paul fight as well with mayweather
it's like mayweather didn't want to take
any chances because it just wasn't worth
the risk but mayweather still did enough
to make sure he won the fight and i just
think tyron really just didn't do that
and it's weird too because jake landed
big shots on him and it didn't really
seem like it affected ty at all you know
what the fight will look like to me it
looked like one guy who was
clearly going to beat the [ __ ] out of
another guy but the other guy just was
happened to be a little more active
being jake paul that's it and tyron
woodley just didn't pull the trigger man
yeah and that's why it's so frustrating
because you know
even in the boxing context
tom really was going to knock him out
yeah because as we watched jake paul box
more we realized that what he just said
he's a subpar below average amateur
boxer amateur boxer that's what i said
when we did our show right after that i
was like what after i watched his fight
it wasn't like i was like damn bro jake
is good i watched that fight being like
damn he's really not that good he's
sloppy he's all over the place i was
actually shocked how sloppy he was yeah
right because you know i think he feels
crosstalk yeah consciously and against
each other stuff like he was trying to
do fancy footwork that he doesn't know
how to do which i was shocked at because
i do think he really does like the sport
right yeah but it just goes to show that
when the level of competition rises
he all of his stuff just starts to
crumble yeah you start to see how bad he
actually is even though tyron wasn't
doing anything you could tell because
all of his other fighter all those other
fights he knew for i bet you in in his
head against tyrone he was pretty
nervous
he might he might knock me out those
other two fights ben asking the other
guy he knew he was going to walk through
them so he just went straight forward
knocked him out quick we didn't really
get to see it this fight he knew he
couldn't really do that so we got to see
what he actually is you said that weird
thing he'd stand up straight and be like
yeah yeah yeah he's like what the [ __ ]
are you doing like it was he was so bad
but i was so mad because on our show i
was like it doesn't matter if tyron
shows up that night he wins the fight if
he does he still wins the fight right
i'm like bro like i was so mad it's just
weird because in the first round so
tyron woodley comes in he just starts
swinging wild right which shows oh he's
not scared to throw so which kind of led
me to believe that he was going to put
on volume yeah so like i said early on
when he threw his jab it was working but
in this in this context too he didn't
even paw out his jab to even set any
other shots nothing what we found out
about tyler woodley he literally only
has
one shot and that's overhand right
didn't throw jabs no combos nothing
really to the body except for occasional
cross of the body here and there which
by the way it [ __ ] connected jackass
like he didn't do the stuff that was
working and the weird thing was too is
that when he did a double pump fake
guess what it was the overhand that
connected up top to jake and basically
knocked him down but the ropes kept him
up was one which is a knockdown yeah
yeah
keep you up dude the ropes normally have
those those little strips in the middle
in the middle yeah dude for boxing they
do even kickboxing they do too really
[ __ ] i always feel like i used to see
videos of people just going through the
room
i think it might be later like newer oh
okay but i i do remember them being
there pretty often look at that [ __ ]
though that double pump fake he double
pump fake pow hit him with that overhand
it's like so okay so you realize that
these fakes work right and once again
i'm not saying this as i'm a boxer as
well but somebody who's been watching
boxing now for years it's like we could
tell what works as a viewer and you guys
can too you've seen it his the fakes
works volume always [ __ ] works you
can't just have one punch they know
what's coming enough volume needs to
work yeah right and it's it's he just
didn't pull the trigger enough
and even with his mma career right he's
never been been a big boxing combination
guy
he would always just kind of wait for
that big shot and if he didn't land that
big shot early
the fight would be kind of relatively
uneventful right unless he got a
takedown or less something else happened
and that's why like in the wonder boy
fight there was a lot of moments where
yeah there's just nothing happened
damien maya and you would watch damian
maya
fight tyron whitley and you're like
dude just knock him yeah
yeah dude because it's like you're
stuffing the takedown you you eliminated
the threats which is great perfect
but what do you do something yeah you
have to do something a little bit more
unfortunately that's what was crazy too
is after he hurt jake and they separated
and they went he just went back to the
middle and just stood there which was so
weird because dude i'm like bro jake was
seeing stars yeah it's like
he's seeing stars his eyes were like
slightly glazed over he was like
wobbling i'm like and he just started to
swing his arm like this chill boning
doing a little nate diaz type of [ __ ]
it's like you just need to throw a few
he just threw a couple straight shots
down the middle man did you see at the
end of i think it was like the third
round or so he actually threw his one
straight right and it connected at the
end of the round and that's the thing
it's like especially with mma well at
least with these guys the guys that
fought it's like just throw more
straight punches the overhands are great
but like at a certain point in time you
have to just change the angle a little
bit and if you want low risk high reward
your straight shots are always going to
be and it's easier to land in overhand
when your gloves are this big yeah yeah
like when the gloves are bigger i mean
it's it's easier to block that [ __ ] and
yeah that was my thing i was just i was
like sitting there yelling like bro just
[ __ ] throw yeah and then like he
would cut him off yeah he would cut him
off and when he has him cut off
nothing he would just let him eventually
circle right back down and get his space
and i was just like bro tyron come the
[ __ ] on that's just so pissed but the
one good thing that we know about tyron
is that at least he's consistent across
the board yeah even if he's fighting a
[ __ ] trash can like just gonna be
boring no matter what he's just not
gonna throw enough
but [ __ ] we out my fingers are crossed i
was so confident bro i totally lost me
money you know what the crazy thing is
too guy's [ __ ] 40 years old right
yeah faster than jake paul yeah he's way
faster than him like
substantially faster i was surprised at
his speed but then when you look at it
look at his [ __ ] mma stance when he's
boxing yeah yeah that was another thing
too
[ __ ] and the one thing i was hoping for
i was like i i was hoping that jake paul
would throw combinations
tyron really would just block black
block and just throw one down the middle
yeah or something right after but even
off the counters there was nothing there
and i was expecting him to take
advantage of that because
if one thing that tom woody's really
good at he's a pretty good counter
puncher yeah right like that's in his
skill set but he still didn't pull the
trigger enough on the counter punches
and i was like dude if you're going to
knock out a guy like jake paul it's
going to be through the counter punch
yeah right yeah but it was not coming
yeah yeah that's the thing too with him
like he just wasn't a boxer yeah and you
know people can say as much as they want
well he just started boxing that's not
what he said i'm doing it based on what
he said in these interviews he says i've
been boxing my whole life you guys just
haven't seen it so and when he said that
didn't we all feel way more comfortable
exactly hell yeah he watched the open
workouts he's throwing these long ass
combos and [ __ ] honestly in the open
workouts that [ __ ] made me nervous yeah
little short punches like it was just
like he just didn't look very smooth
like it didn't look like
uh i in the beginning of his camps i
felt like to me
he looked a little bit better on the
pads and the rhythm and all that stuff
but his mental confidence was a lot
better towards the end of the fight cam
yeah yeah but his skills and my eyes
like to what i would see i just was like
i don't know also too like it was it was
very representative with the way he did
his uh his pad work was how he was
throwing to in terms of how short his
extension boom
like these shorts yeah it just wasn't by
the way too if you guys don't know
um when i looked at the stats jake paul
and tyler woodley same arm length same
reach
same [ __ ] reach yeah so just jake is
just a little taller than him that's all
that it is and that kind of actually
works to his advantage especially if he
knows that if he if he would have
changed at the angle in which he struck
him like legit because of how fast he
was if he would have just stuck that jab
straight down the pipe in the middle he
would have cracked him so easy all day
especially after the lame ass jabs that
jake paul was throwing out that's when
you throw that overhand you just time it
boom over the top because
they weren't really doing anything like
at no point in time did i ever feel like
tyron woodley was in trouble yeah and i
think the
what [ __ ] with his head was that he
got touched yeah but
you're gonna get touched you're gonna
get touched it doesn't matter if it's
jake paul or [ __ ] cm punk or whatever
if you're standing in front of a guy
your intent is to knock somebody out
that's just gonna happen like i was
watching a bunch of old nick diaz fights
right because i'm excited for him to
come back
this dude he takes a couple shots but
he's his eyes are right on you and he's
still touching you while you're floyd
gets hit yeah yeah it gets hit it's like
you're not it's not even it doesn't
matter if it's a guy that's just on the
street he might still [ __ ] hit you
yeah take one give two yeah exactly and
that's the thing that floyd does right
he'll get hit but he goes all right i'm
gonna make you pay for that and it does
make you pay for that either best
example of that [ __ ] triple g baby yeah
look at triple g gangster crack by
canelo
my thing with tyron is why wouldn't you
just come out aggressive
like in my head it was like you really
think you're going to win a decision
here like you think they're going to let
you buy one yeah it's like but do you
think you're gonna they're gonna let you
win it i thought
in my mind like how i was scoring in my
head
i was like oh yeah i don't know what
they want he did more damage he did the
most damage in the fight because jake
you know landed here and there but he
was just kind of running around and he
got really tired towards the end but
they're not going to let him lose that's
the whole thing it's like you know just
boxing a lot it's boxing we see they see
it all the time the cur it's corrupt
there's these decisions where you're
like what the [ __ ] you really think
they're gonna let their cash cow right
now lose a fight in his hometown yeah
bringing all this money to ohio i i did
this uh event i was filming for my
friends that have like a golf thing and
uh one of these other guys was there is
from there he's like man i hate he's
like i hate when he says that [ __ ] he's
like yeah he was born in ohio so he's
like but he's not from there he's like
you go down there no one [ __ ] cares
about jake paul yeah
he's like no you talk about the crowd
yeah and that's when there was someone
on the crowd saying like oh honestly
like there sounds like there's a better
reaction for tyron than there is for uh
jake out here yeah dude yeah i mean
that's what he was saying he's like
trust me people out there don't [ __ ]
with jake paul like he's making it seem
like nobody does it really right it was
just
who else was on that card besides jake
paul and tyler woodley amanda
serrano yeah did you hear what jake
paul's trying to do now he's gonna put
amanda nunez after her right yeah man is
beat her ass i think yeah maybe i mean i
don't know like that's who knows anymore
well that's the thing too it's just
boxing is just a different set of rules
yeah you know and it's like it's also
when you come play their game
just because they have a little more
time under that sport and that rule set
there's a lot of nuances especially when
the lights are on yeah it's one thing if
you're boxing into the gym that's that's
a totally different thing but once the
lights are on then you kind of revert
back to and that's how i feel about
tyron right he just went back to what he
does yeah what he knows and it's not i
don't think he just had enough time to
to to prepare mentally and all this
stuff for the boxing fight it could have
been more optimal was he effective yeah
probably but he could have been more
optimal if he had more time just
mentally [ __ ] up man especially
because you know when the with the
vicente lucay fight if you guys ever
watched that fight
he got his ass beat by vicente luca but
yeah at the same time he was cracking
the [ __ ] out of him he's doing good
vicente luke is just known to have the
thickest skull on earth he's he's down
for firefights yeah all his fights are
fired stephen wonderboy broke both of
his hands on his head
he got a big-ass head bro exactly
he hit him with a hard overhand
connected and then luke was wobble but
he still stood there and i don't even
know how that happened yeah but it's
just but i think it's just it just
depends on you know i think the
selection of fires that we've had go to
boxing is why we're getting the results
that we're getting he's also not finding
people his size either yeah yeah and but
it's like you see anderson silva he's
doing good oh i mean but anderson silva
dude look up that look up just him
sparring a pro boxer at wild card that's
what i'm saying in the corner just
running circles around this guy it is
funny though to see like you know him
and dana jake and dana have their beef
and dana's or dana's like hey
anderson silva's free i don't hear you
calling out anderson silva jake jj and
jake just tries to play it off and [ __ ]
and go to another fighter because it's
like he wants jorge he wants warriors
bro we don't think he was that either
you could tell that you're scared of man
like he just saw what anderson silva did
yeah and to a
pro boxer and then well tito ortiz
looked like [ __ ] dude
we knew it was but the thing is is like
i
tito does have a pretty good chin like
he's pretty durable if there's one like
thing you could say about tito whether
you like him or not he's a pretty
durable tough
like he's a dog he's gonna go out there
and and and always do his best he's
built like a lego that's exactly he got
no neck he has a big head he got a big
ass big old dome yeah it looks like one
of those statues but what the [ __ ] was
he thinking going out there doing what
he was doing he only threw looping shots
but it was just like the sequence that
he got knocked out with he was just like
what
he was like he was like tap tap
his wrist was like this too he's like
tap like tap and he got [ __ ] up like
bro what are you doing i think he really
thought he was just gonna dirty box him
and just like catch them ahead or just
be like oh yeah i'm going to control i'm
going to be able to control this fight
be the bigger guy right but it's like
you must have forgot who anderson silva
is right and he was looking for that
setup the whole fight he was looking for
that we weave overhand and he almost
landed a couple times in the last one
i think jake's calling out jorge heavy
because he knows that dana white's not
gonna not let him do it of course that's
why he's calling in my head so he can be
like see i'm not scared of let me fight
your striker jake just hit up the
grandpa anderson silva yeah let let just
beat up the grandpa man yeah
just beat him up
dude the way he put it on julio chavez
jr was nuts and i'm like this
[ __ ] is ready to box you should
fight julius caesar travis jr
that would be great you should take who
uh anderson silva lost uh a beat that'd
be [ __ ] fantastic he'll probably
choose [ __ ] tito and go knock out
tito i would like to see oscar de la
hoya versus [ __ ] jake paul oh that'd
be great soon i would love that [ __ ]
dude yeah dude trtv tour
that [ __ ] short hook landed flush
yeah it was hard i i didn't i couldn't
see it because they had it from the back
when you were watching the fight i'm
like what what the [ __ ] happened like
how did he get he's like you didn't hit
him that hard and then you see the
replay of the actual angle perfect the
hardest little short hook dude yeah the
turnbuckle went through the rope i meant
when i first because i didn't watch like
the actual fight when it happened right
i watched it afterwards and at first i
saw the highlights
and i'm like it looked weird to me
because you saw it from like the back
angle and then cheetos down there and it
kind of looks like he's smiling and i'm
like and then the whole thing with him
doing these weird little taps it looked
like they were timing because anderson
was going down so it was like one
two and three and then he came over and
i was like but then you watch it in
slow-mo you're like oh no anderson threw
on him hard like he threw harder
and knocked his ass out rotated around
him and then pink one more i'm like
jesus just he just makes it look so easy
yeah i think if jake's smart he fights
that fury guy because
that makes sense i was talking to you
about it because i had never seen him
fight before did you watch the fury guy
i did watch him fight i was like sucks
too oh he's not does he suck yeah i was
i thought he was pretty good i i didn't
see the fight though okay i don't want
to say i heard he was probably he
doesn't suck but he's not as good as you
think he's going to sharon jake is a
good fight yeah it might be like a good
fight
it makes more sense for them the levels
are equal yeah the levels are i think
are more equal i think fiori probably
has better footwork because watching
jake fight tyron he was tripping and he
was crossing his feet and clumsy um but
i think that's a better fight you know
for jake i think it's a smarter fight
and it's fun it kind of gives him more
credit because he's fighting an actual
boxer but this is a boxer that he could
probably actually be i think personally
but um i hope he fights anderson because
anderson's put him on his [ __ ] ass
and
uh
if they give him jorge i think jorge
does a work with his [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
that fight won't happen trt vitor bell
that fight too
but even that dude like
i kind of like man i'm like vitor what
are you doing bro i mean if you look at
this so if you guys don't know so vitor
belfort is the first
uh ufc heavyweight no he's the youngest
yeah youngest ufc heavyweight champion
so he's been around since like ufc
[ __ ] one for crying out loud when
they were allowed in the 90s you had
shoes on shoes on people were like
biting each other's chodes and it was
like
it was completely okay but loki they
were yeah
they literally joked but also true yeah
it was it was cop fighting it was human
cop fighting that was actually highly
accurate back in the day but this man
decided he was supposed to fight oscar
de la hoya so oscar de la hoya actually
caught kovit which by the way
fitor belfort is on gear like a
[ __ ] oscar de la hoya got saved
yeah yeah because he would have got
[ __ ] smashed i still think his video
he kind of looks like he's in the office
or the hospital bed
he's like
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah
i was like bruh but yeah yeah so he
caught covered and then evander
holyfield decides to step in i saw
people too if you guys don't know who
evander holyfield is he is the man who
got his ear bitten off by mike tyson
considered one of the greatest
heavyweights in the history of boxing
hey david how old is vitor would you say
estimation about like maybe 44. how old
is uh vanderholyfield 58 damn you're 60.
eight years old the fight was scheduled
to be
in california but the commission
athletic commission hell no was like no
[ __ ] way are you gonna get a
last-minute replacement
from a guy who's 58 and who hasn't
fought
in 10 to 12 years
okay so what do they do they go to
florida
all good they move the entire event to
florida to allow these guys to [ __ ]
fight that's how crazy this whole thing
bro so i i had heard rumors right that
like evander was gonna fight mike tyson
again right that would have been a
disaster yeah so it's like all right and
when they first announced it i was like
oh you know maybe he's you know he's
been training for mike tyson he might
look fine but then when the open workout
video came out i was like bro this needs
to be ended like this needs to not
happen
sent it into the group chat and i'm like
this is not real
this is not real
he can't even lift his elbow to throw a
hook yeah and look what happened in the
fight if you watch the and we call him
trtv tour because he's on so much
steroids it's unreal yeah he is jacked
out of his mind they did a comparison
picture of
before he was on trt
and then when he got on trt
and then when he stopped being on trt to
now and he looks just like the way he
did physique wise when he was on trt
because there's no [ __ ] way he's not
on gear and why wouldn't you be on gear
yeah of course
what are they going to test yeah and so
literally evander decides to throw his
the best hook that he can and he spun
around like a [ __ ] looney tunes i
thought he got dropped i know and he
fell through the ropes right yeah it
looked like it but he just he he just
threw his weak weak hook because
something's wrong with his shoulder yeah
his shoulder is [ __ ] up through it
you know
yeah with years of experiencing boxing
decades
or yeah and then he spins around like a
little cartoon and goes to the ropes
that [ __ ] broke my heart dude yeah
evander [ __ ] holyfield if you guys
pay for the trailer event
just do anything else just give your
money to davis yeah please just venmo
david okay i beg of you please don't
spend money on these events because
this is not okay
yeah dude when i saw them opening i was
i literally it almost kind of makes you
it almost kind of made me feel like sick
to my stomach yeah like you're like bro
really like this is the fight they're
gonna have like evander obviously
is going to lose like there's no way you
see the difference in the open workout
there's a all right uh vitor's over
there doing these [ __ ] like long ass
combos and moving good hitting hard as
[ __ ] and then evander's like really
[ __ ] amanda's like slow ass cross the
body slow ass hook i'm like bro okay
they're joking this is what they need to
do they need to level the playing field
give a vander like three months cycle of
[ __ ] gear and then run it back no but
he looks and shoots dude by the way this
is good genetics
holyfield
age like his face of a 60 year old body
of a 35 year old why does he look
younger than oscar de la hoya i don't
[ __ ] know coke because my boy
is out here just while hooking up that's
right
started training until right before it's
like the hat the happy snow dude but
honestly though triller fights are
[ __ ] garbage dog you want to say like
it's the equivalent to like
the met gala dog yes like what the [ __ ]
is the met gallow and what the [ __ ] is
trailer fight it feels so cheap right it
feels like a low end like all it is is
for views and clout that's all these
[ __ ] events are and it's like okay
this is fine but then look what's
happening vander holyfield who wants to
watch a 58 year old former pro legendary
hall of fame boxer
fight this brazilian dude mma fighter
who's on all the gear like what is the
point of watching this fight legit he
could have died he could have died yeah
and that's the reason why california was
like no thank you bro take that's just
somewhere else that should show you
something i i'm if florida is like
florida should be ashamed of themselves
yeah like they're lighting that [ __ ]
that's not brand new that's not brand
before like yeah
in florida
of course it literally last week got
changed because hard rock casino right
yeah california was like have you heard
evander holyfield uh speak in an
interview see that's the other thing
it's like crazy this guy has no business
getting knocked out again like why is he
putting himself through him and james
tony if they had a conversation you
would need the translation with like the
bouncy ball on the bottom
that's it it's like pixar's little thing
is jumping up and down there was like
there was like a clip of it was like a
simple question to evander holyfield
it's like so what do you think you're
gonna do in this match uh you know i'm
coming round it
we're gonna
you know we're just gonna like for like
five minutes straight and uh who's gonna
let this guy box yeah crazy triller is
true of course what the [ __ ] is trillard
a chinese company they don't care is it
yeah that's the slogan
i don't care that's the bouncing ball
yeah somebody can die
it is weird right but how much money are
they even really making right who knows
this chinese company dude they're making
something off the back end getting
everybody's information ccp [ __ ] i don't
care what's crazy about it i don't know
why it makes you me think about it but
the whole i i don't care thing you also
you saw the new thing with demetrius
johnson oh his next fight bro he's
fighting rod tang in what what rules so
here's the mma kickboxing yes first
round lit first round muay thai second
round mma third round muay thai fourth
round mma with the fifth one i had to
forget i don't even know what the [ __ ] i
don't even
but so they can only do muay thai one
round the next round they can do mma
well second round he's gonna get eaten
up this podcast is brought to you by
vivino my friends do i love
my vivino do i love my wine listen i
don't know much about wine but vavino
makes it super easy vavino is the
world's biggest online wine marketplace
they're also the largest online wine
community with 50 million users who have
rated and reviewed just about every
wine let me tell you something i love
myself a little little savion blanks a
little merlots you know what i'm talking
about a little chardonnays yup and their
app is everything has everything i'm
sorry you need to know about wine listen
if you don't know crap about wine vivino
is going to be your best friend all you
have to do is scan a bottle when you're
shopping and you can see what vivino
users have to say about it and the
reviews are super dope too because it
goes into descriptors that i understand
i love it i really stepped up my wine
game thanks to vivino give them a try
and i know you're going to love it go to
vivino.com brain and use codebrain at
checkout to save twenty percent on your
first order of up to two hundred dollars
that's v i v i n o dot com slash brain
code brain to save twenty percent on
your first order of up to two hundred
dollars vivino dot com slash brain code
brain see cipher details terms apply
nah dude it's gonna be fine
i mean for this bro this is kind of cool
this is lit yeah i remember back in the
day when i was starting to like compete
and stuff they used to do these events
where they would do first round boxing
three-round fight first round boxing
second round kickboxing third round mma
that's like bully beat down that is it
that is always really beat down yeah
they would do the same [ __ ] but it was
lit like bro the best fights would
happen like because it was so fun
because you get a guy who is a boxer and
you're like oh [ __ ] he's [ __ ] this
kickboxer up in the first round and then
second round fight would completely
change third round and then just see
what happens but usually the mma guy
usually wins they can make the third
round but sometimes they don't make it
the third round and it's like dope as
[ __ ] back is pushed you back down this
is good but yeah that is bully beat down
that is literally bully beat down dude
wow with uh mayhem miller yeah he's that
guy he's got arrested again for domestic
or something yeah wait first of all
who's the girl that ended up with him i
have no idea who the [ __ ] looks at
mayhem miller goes this is the guy i
want to be with
girls out there like fighters man it
sucks because it's like you can tell
it's all those guys back in the day that
just couldn't get it going yeah yeah
except bj because bj got it going right
here's the champ but they're just like
stefan bonner's went wild oh stephen
bonner he was trying to get more pain
killers right and yeah you know they try
to hold him because they found out that
he had abuse i'm sure yeah they have
signs of abuse they try to hold him and
then he started flipping out and had
this whole thing it was crazy because i
saw a little bit of it he was saying
like my doctor won't see me i ran out of
my painkillers but he ran out of his
painkillers way too soon yeah it's like
like this will last you two months he's
like all right i'm back from martha like
sir it's been a day yeah
he's like yeah they were really affected
great thank you but stefan botter has i
mean stephen bought a lost the [ __ ]
tito ortiz yeah that's true and like in
like tito ortiz's heydays like when it
was all over when he was [ __ ] stupid
oh i never liked tito nobody liked
actually you did didn't you you little i
hated tito no all the people that used
to train with that like really like
teeth ortiz never liked them they were
usually [ __ ]
i hated teenagers
don't be like tito when the [ __ ] big
bellied iceman came through and beat his
ass that made me so happy so happy what
made me even dislike tito moore is when
he knocked out chocolate l when chuck
liddell was like [ __ ] almost 60 years
old he was a vander holyfield yeah and
then he the way karma the way that he
celebrated
like he celebrated like he just won the
gold medal in the olympics if they had
it in there you would celebrate too if
this guy beat the [ __ ] out of you
it's like beating a boss in a video he's
a little disappointed in beater belfor
because after you know he beats
holyfield he's like [ __ ] yeah i'm like
come on guys the juice though that ain't
him that's what she was talking though
and his pimple started popping on his
face
but i didn't like shriveling up yeah i
understand vitor but at the same time
it's like bruh
like why why are you asking though
that's boho why are you energy why are
you fighting this guy dude you know what
you're gonna do
like it's like
i don't know to me it's just weird it's
funny these fighters are getting [ __ ]
weird dude [ __ ] conor mcgregor my my
favorite he's disappointing me this will
try to assault uh mgk mgk machine gun
because that's a fight that he can
actually win
this will be him
so much too crazy bro he's too crazy
he's too wild with his uh one came up to
uh was it uh megan fox and asked and was
like hey let's take a picture and then
mgk just puts his hand on him and she
goes nah that's what happened huh that's
what happened
so mgk kind of had it coming to him i
guess this is what i read like he just
came up he goes nah and he like shoves
conor and connor's like the [ __ ] yeah
you know
if that's actually what happened mgk
you're a [ __ ] idiot you deserve to
get your ass back yeah yeah because
you're at the front row at all these
[ __ ] fights yeah yeah it's like come
through and apparently like there was
all these these stories about how megan
fox was saying how like she's a way
bigger fan than he is like he don't
really [ __ ] with ufc apparently but
also too who wants megan fox dude she
her [ __ ] [ __ ] probably has teeth in
it but like who wants mgk yeah what is
of it it's like mjk really you over here
pushing
like any fighter like bro
is his music any good you know he's
actually a pretty decent rapper
yeah
he raps fast
let's not forget that he's the only one
that challenged eminem and his [ __ ] was
not bad his diss record wasn't bad yeah
it's just amazing was better i mean he
got murdered yeah
that's also eminem like that's his
wheelhouse like
this track was not bad yeah there's two
white guys is a fair fight bro
he can say
and then the pictures you can see mgk is
kind of just like
yeah it's like bro yeah it's conor
mcgregor like even with his busted leg
he will yeah you up but also the thing
about conor you have to respect is that
he's trying to fight everybody he fought
an old man that's right
oh man bro he find a bus bro he's trying
to fight bus he tried to fight mgk
why because the old man he can win a
blessed one
beef though bros before us won't fight
back he broke him dude yeah habib
literally broke him in well it's also
like i think he just broke himself like
cocaine is a hell of a drug dog i just
think it's this and we see it in any
weight division you can only get so far
with just having some punching power do
you do you agree with habib's comment
about uh jose aldo
uh
i don't
well he what did he say he said like
jose aldo probably won't have a second
prime because there is no second prime
um
he was basically saying you saw him beat
uh pedro munoz and you think that he's
getting better he's not getting better
he doesn't have a second prime i think
he what he said is kind of like it is
kind of out of pocket but if you ask me
if i think he's
did when he beat pedro munoz yeah that
was great but did we all expect him to
be pedro munoz
yeah
do i think he's gonna be peter yan if
they fight for the title i don't think
so i think you have a good shot but i
really don't think peter youne
is like peter gone has all
the advantages on his side right
but is jose aldo like still growing
until 135 yeah definitely
is it kind of a hot take from khabib
yeah maybe but
i don't really think it's that out of
pocket you know but
what jose said about habib was quite
interesting he kind of clapped back and
was saying well
you know everybody's going to lose
eventually you chose to leave before you
could lose exactly right
you know what kind of the same way i
feel about that is the same way i feel
about jose's comment i was like oh a
little out of pocket but kind of true
yeah
like they both had fair yeah yeah and i
think how big would agree with that yeah
because he what how many title defenses
does jose have 10 or nine yeah it was he
didn't lose in 10 years by the way yeah
like before conor knocked him out he was
the pound for pound number one
like it was like him and jon jones going
back and forth every year right but they
were the both those guys were the most
dominant guys at that time and anybody
that would fight them you'd already be
like oh yeah jose got that [ __ ] yeah but
when it comes to like and they try to
compare the records of habib's first
guys and jose aldo's first guys which is
kind of a fair argument but at the same
time it's not really because
you look at the resume of guys that jose
alda beat
it's just also different eras yeah like
the guys that jose beat on his come up
were just it was such a different time
the sport was still evolving habib
probably beat the guys that had more an
evolved modern day mma game yeah you
know so it is a little different but
they're both right like they're i think
there's truth in some and what they're
both talking about but
it is i do want to see jose alda do well
though like i it is exciting to see him
do very well at 135 from that first
peter yanfi i honestly i thought he was
winning until he got finished and then
he just got cast out i mean i still
think to this day like yeah if he would
just had better cardio in that fight he
probably could have won it um but that's
the thing right now is like jan is
younger and he has you know hit time is
on his side to grow yeah and get better
and get faster and all that type of [ __ ]
josie doesn't really have that but i i
honestly like even seeing tj fight this
last fight even though i thought san
hagen won like i think jose could still
maybe take it i mean he's only 32. yeah
he's still [ __ ] young people forget
that dude just because he's just saying
what i just said if you forget that he's
only 32 still actually so yeah i think
jan's 30 or 31 yeah he's like almost the
same age right but styles really make
everything yeah and you look at yon's
style like he could take
hard hits a lot of damage because he
knows how to fight in the pocket so
whenever someone's fighting him
he could absorb a lot and a lot of them
are glancing blows they're hitting arms
but he knows how to roll punches and
counter and he has a very versatile game
yeah he stays very blocky right yeah and
sometimes he'll just be like all right
go ahead throw and he did that with with
he he knows how to survive in fights and
he knows he did that against al joe and
eventually just beat the [ __ ] out of him
yeah until that fight too
boy right there yeah
but but also it's like when you get a
guy like jose if those guys were to jose
were to fight peter young again i think
eight times out of ten jose yes in my
personal yeah you know yeah and it's not
because jose is like not that good or
anything like that i just think the
style kind of feeds more to peter young
i just think he's the more efficient
fighter at one thirty five peter young
was very surprising with his trips and
his takedown he slept on bro like i was
crazy he's very underrated i was talking
mad [ __ ] about him too oh yeah
i want to see jose and tj
oh that would be amazing
yeah i think uh i think yeah because
jose just won tj just won i think if
jose can beat tj i think he can be the
champion you know and shout outs to tj
killashaw thriller shaw for coming off
what a two-year
no-fight stint yeah and then showing
that type of performance even after he
tore his knee in the first or second
round that was kind of crazy yeah yeah
like literally toys that [ __ ] ripped
right yeah he cory sanhed he hooked the
[ __ ] out of it i was like oh that's it
when i saw that happen i was like oh
cory san hager won and i kind of stopped
watching the fight a little bit as
because i was like cooking and stuff and
i was doing stuff but i kind of talked
about this [ __ ]
i get in the kitchen [ __ ]
you were cooking the steak rice and
veggies yeah
[ __ ] doc but yeah so like i really did
think
oh tj that's the fight's done but he
came back and he hung in there he was
still moving and he did what he needed
to do to win like you may not agree with
the decision but yeah he still did
enough and corey sanhagan didn't really
address some of those positions as best
he could have how do you like tear your
knee and still move like that
i think i think it's just the adrenaline
bro that [ __ ] was crazy dude it's just
the epo yeah yeah
hey man we gotta let that go man
honestly like different man know what
just made me re-mad again because we
were talking about this at the shop was
we're sitting there talking about how
nick diaz is coming back and [ __ ] it's
like bro he was suspended for five years
four weeks
tj got two years for admitting to taking
something to cheat that is the like the
scariest thing to have better cardio and
to recover more different era too two
years
for that he got five years for a week
believe they didn't overturn that [ __ ]
in the first year yeah it's insane it's
probably because nicodemus was like [ __ ]
it it just didn't true i'm sure he could
have pushed it like i'm sure there was
ways he could have worked around but he
just wanted to complain instead and
honestly i'm really excited maybe he
needed those five years off maybe he
just needed to take time away nervous
i'm super nervous dude but the thing
about the diaz brothers right it's like
their best attribute
is it their speed it is it their
endurance yeah it's their endurance and
their mentality like those guys like you
look at leon right when leon fought nate
diaz oh i was like leon is gonna be
breaks off this dude and he did
up until he just kind of chilled when he
wasn't really supposed to and nate diaz
made him [ __ ] pay for it right
hardest cross ever dude yeah and and how
many guys do you think would be able to
pull that off in the fifth round when
they're getting oh nobody
to be able to just be like oh i'm gonna
put it on him and try to still finish
yeah and he could have won that fight
too he wasn't [ __ ] around yeah yeah
he wasn't being a diaz brother yeah
if he wasn't being a [ __ ] tyron
woodley yeah
um
the whole thing that makes me nervous
about nick is just like a couple years
back i remember we had talked about it
when it happened but there was a video
that came out of him sparring boxing he
got [ __ ] flatlined yeah that wasn't
him this podcast is sponsored by better
help is there something interfering with
your happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals listen we have all
been there and there's a weird stigma
around therapy but you guys have to
understand i've been doing therapy for a
very long time and i've been using
better help and better help has been
really really great for me because for
me because i'm always on the go and
sometimes i need that little mental
health help better help is great because
my therapist is you know it's available
you can even start communicating under
48 hours and trust me my friends it's
not a crisis line it's not self-help
it's actual professional therapy done
securely on
line there's so many great things about
it better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they can even make it easy for you to
change therapists if you need so for me
when i had my first therapist uh it was
you know she was okay but i decided to
just switch it up and give it a go and i
found a therapist that matched for me
and i've been sticking with the same
therapist for quite a while now so my
friends visit betterhelp.com genius
that's better h-e-l-p and join
the over 2
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better health
that they are recruiting additional
therapists in all 50 states special
offer for my genius brain listeners get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
genius once again that's b e t t e r h e
l p
dot com slash genius and get 10 off your
first month
that was him
yeah and it was like he got flatlined
and you know like i remember watching
the interview with him and ariel johanna
we talk about james tony and [ __ ] man
like
i get anxiety trying to listen to him
talk i'm just like i'm like it makes me
move i'm like bro just speak like yeah
you're like
but then he's still fighting right and
he's been away for a long time he's
older well he's like 37 now yeah and
it's just like robbie lawler i think
it's the best fight that he can come
back to because robbie is older too but
might look the best yeah but my whole
thing is he has been more active though
at least robbie still has a chin robbie
is still tough as [ __ ] nails it's
just he's slower he's just not as active
and the one of the funniest things
people said was when he fought colby
covington because till this day i think
uh robbie lawler's still bobbing and
weaving
but that should show you something he
can still move yeah man he was sitting
there just doing this for five five
minute rounds but nick was smart with
this because you know they worked it
into it's a five-round fight dude
[ __ ] uh did you hear recently too
that uh
there was a person who was a
transgendered uh we watched this [ __ ]
yeah bro that fight did you watch it yes
i did it's awful it's [ __ ] terrible
and look here here's the best example of
like why
this can't be a regular especially their
kid like this uh i think her name was
alana right yeah and alana's she's the
transgender uh mma fighter she fought in
the promotion combat the americas and
she fought this french chick i forgot
her name which again shout out to that
friend she was pretty good like she was
piecing it uh alana up like all day but
uh before she transitioned she was like
a special forces like yeah
she was huge
huge you can obviously she got tribal
tattoos so you already know what it
looks like
when she transitioned
she like obviously lost some muscle mass
but
she looks like a
she looks like a pretty big person i
watched this video
you know there was this video of this uh
it was a podcast because it just said
popped up when you searched it it was
like it's it's like a transgender and a
lesbian girl that have a podcast and you
know i was like oh i want to see what
you know perspective their perspective
is and they're like they think how we
all think
she was like i think most yes like most
people in general
community would agree she was saying
she's like she's like you know there's
there's no scientifical proof to show
how long it takes to lose what you had
from being a man right yeah um bone
density yeah but that's what she said
she's like but what we know is she's
like look at her arms she obviously
still has [ __ ] arms from you know
back then she's like you can tell that
her hands are still big from back then
she has way bigger joints than her yeah
and she had said she's like she was like
look um this isn't like a sport like us
transgenders go into like soccer where
it's like just skill you know endurance
and skill she's like this is a sport
where you're going to literally
physically hurt somebody you're trying
to hurt somebody she's like it's just
not fair especially because of how long
she was a man for
and i'm just like you know i couldn't i
couldn't agree anymore and it's just
like well
she definitely saw that fight that's why
she saw somebody who was way more
skilled than her piecing her up didn't
do jack [ __ ] what just landed one punch
yeah one
punch and that's the body shot and she
was like oh and the fact that she this
this [ __ ] was tough it's a man yeah she
was like
hey bro like like you said you said we
out here and and he mentioned that when
she got cracked with the first overhand
her face was like whoa
she got cracked she literally went
oh she was like what the [ __ ] was that
and that's when you could tell like yeah
obviously alana she has no striking
skill at all because that other girl was
beating her the [ __ ] up and she tries to
use that excuse look she beat me up the
whole first round she almost said i'm
like just because you suck yeah but once
you finally just landed something she
was like oh my any shitty shot
and and the thing is too right it's like
she said something like she could have
died
yeah like that's that's not the
takedowns too yeah that's the takedown
was just like strength it was just pure
strength like there was no technique to
the takedown she was just like
right i'm done youtube piecing me up
because i can't strike it's like holy
[ __ ]
and when it comes to a sport like mma
right obviously the goal is to kind of
destroy the other opponent right
but then on top of that too it's like
this is in a position where
you could if you if you're a transgender
woman
why not fight other transgender women
that want to fight yeah because i'm sure
there's other transgender women that
want to fight and that want to live out
that dream of being an mma fighter i
don't think that should be taken away
from them but at the same time it's like
it should be in a league of their own
they're because that's probably the only
way like in any other sport like soccer
you brought up that probably won't be
able to happen because just the amount
of people that are transitioning that
want to play soccer probably get smaller
and smaller and smaller so you won't be
able to have a whole other separate team
so it makes a little more sense there
but darts do darts
is low-key fun bro
and a lot of the the transgender uh mma
fighter she was saying i want to carry
on the legacy
of fallon fox and fallon fox was another
famous
transgender mma fighter that was
murdering women murdering the [ __ ] out
of people and then she got knocked out
stopped fighting yeah
never heard from her again but she alana
says i want to carry on the legacy of
fallon fox there was no legacy and look
i understand if you look up to somebody
who has been in your shoes because i'm
sure it's a tough position to be in like
i could never understand i'm not going
to sit here and tell you what you should
feel what it should be like
but
that does make me raise an eyebrow when
i hear someone say that especially when
if you are amazing at your craft and the
skill and the sport of mma and you're
gonna go out there and fight other women
that's one thing to be said
but alana doesn't look like she even
cares about training she's obviously on
a skill level not taking this seriously
yeah and
she's just using her attributes to win
fights and at the end of the day she's
going to find someone that's going to
knock her the [ __ ] out but there's going
to be a lot of other women that are
going to fight her until it happens i
never thought that i would ever see an
mma fighter that looked worse than cm
punk yeah oh bro it was terrible cm punk
would light her ass up dude and cm punk
should not win like if sam punk had that
skill and he fought someone of
the same skill level of the french girl
that alana fought
cm punk would have got [ __ ] destroyed
if you've got another guy the the thing
in that other the video i was talking
about that i thought was you know
was pretty like intense and like you
know like the big point of the video she
had said this the transgender girl that
was talking saying she's like
i just think it's a little weird and
it's a little selfish how you know she
was in the army she was a man all the
way up into 2010 i guess is when she
transitioned she's like but you never
wanted to be an mma fighter before then
she's like all of a sudden you
transitioned to a female and then you
wanted to be an mma fighter yeah she's
like i think that's a little selfish and
i think that's a little weird how once
you turn into a woman you want to start
fighting women you know what happened
somebody said to her if you can't beat
him join him and she was like
and she's like
yeah so it's just it's like it sucks i
mean because like you know obviously you
don't want to offend anybody and [ __ ]
but in these situations this is a sport
where you can kill somebody yeah a
hundred and a second and if you have an
opinion on this and you think like this
should happen because i i did go on
twitter and i wanted to see what the
consensus was yeah i never seen anything
and a lot of them a lot of the tweets
that were talking about this was like yo
this is [ __ ] up and if you feel like
this is okay just watch the fight and
then you just because it's very it's a
very visceral feeling right like when
you're watching something like this
you you get like i was kind of getting
emotional bro yeah you feel a certain
way about that [ __ ] i was watching this
with tiff and and she was like yo i
getting horny and [ __ ] like she's
getting bowed up
all the time
she's trying to yeah bro they go to the
same dinner again
yeah and then but then tip was like yo
this is kind of [ __ ] up yeah she's
like this is [ __ ] up i i i just
remember finally watching the fight
watching the first round right the girl
is getting pieced the [ __ ] up and i'm
watching it and i'm like oh it's not
that you know
that they're both this way and so i'm
like oh she just [ __ ] sucks at
striking yeah she can't strike but then
when you watch
the second round comes around and you
see one of those takedowns and i'm like
oh well you could see the strength right
there yes that was a horrible takedown
she just picked her up and threw her but
then she landed that overhand and i
looked at the girl's face and got hit
she went
she was like like i'm like okay so this
is like dangerous she took a lot of
shots yeah like every body shot you can
see that she was trying not to show it
but every time she got it she went yup
that's a man i'm like that's a man this
is so bad this first chick
[ __ ] i really feel bad that i forgot her
name but she was tough as [ __ ]
yes celine and the fact that she [ __ ]
signed up to fight that's why i say hats
off all props to her because she knew at
the end of the day if you're a female
fighter and you want to beat the [ __ ]
out of her go ahead [ __ ] do it if you
feel like you could fight and the
competitor in you was like yo i can beat
the shot of this person
[ __ ] go for it i'm not gonna tell you
one thing or another but do i feel like
it's okay i don't know i don't think so
not if you saw the reaction on her face
did you hear the commentators
they were like they did a good job they
were like you know they were talking
about the struggle of the transition
they were telling her story but they
were like
i don't know if this is right you guys
like i don't know what to think
hey they
because it is a very
like
you kind of feel troubled watching it
like you feel some you don't feel good
yeah you don't feel excited the way you
watch jake paul and tyler with exactly
and the whole thing is that
for the people that are for it you know
and maybe they're mad at people not
being for it but it's like you got to
remember this is brand new in our sport
like this [ __ ] don't happen so you can't
expect everybody to be on [ __ ] bored
with this [ __ ] right yeah it's gonna if
it's gonna be okay it's gonna take a
long time listen time the people that
are okay with it they just don't know
any better yeah they've never done the
sport they probably never played really
anything they've probably never even hit
yeah but also too it's like i train with
a lot of men and women
and it's like
even the women will tell you like yeah
there's a there's a difference there's a
difference in strength there's no matter
what especially like say like someone
that's like strong like me or you know
like barred or like that's wrong yeah
that people that like people looked at
me and didn't say nothing yeah i'm like
people have a strong life i was like
there's not even any room why do you
bring it in part
i've been called fat i've been called a
loser
that right there hurt a little bit you
see how he did that he was like he was
like you know like
me or like
like
i've never been so offended in my
[ __ ] life
this will say that
you want to win another play that back
you need to look at the [ __ ] his
we're trying to get to our best self
over here bro none of us have worked out
in like six weeks but hey speak for
yourself bro yeah you've been listening
you haven't worked out in like i was in
the gym with david last week hey i
haven't worked out yet
hey hey let's talk about this [ __ ] right
now
what's up with the [ __ ] weight loss
challenge bro
and hey guys
this wraps up this episode of the genius
brain
uh well uh we will see you guys next
time every thursdays and sundays up
until next year next year it's only
going to be once a week but for now
thursdays and sundays uh you can catch
nick at nick the ear
you can catch alex at lyft god three f's
forever